Finley died in the very early hours of
Christmas Day 2020.
he was in his cot in your bedroom at
home
he died of septicemia
endocarditis and pneumonia
the infections which killed him had all
set in and taken hold
because of the extensive fractures to
thin his ribs and other bones
which acting together you inflicted on
him
and I'm sure you did so before the 16th
of December which was more than nine
days before he died
you both knew that Finley was very
seriously ill and dying as a result of
what you had done to him
yet you deliberately failed to see any
medical help for him
and you deliberately made sure that he
was not seen by anyone who could have
rescued him and taken him away from your
care
medical intervention would have saved
Finley's life
and if Finley had been given antibiotics
and the necessary care in the minutes
and hours before he died
he would have made a complete recovery
he would have been alive today
I'm sure that you both knew Finley was
dead when you dialed 999 at 2 27 am on
Christmas Day
Finley had by that time being dead for
over half an hour
five minutes later there was a very
experienced paramedic on the scene
he had been told there was a pediatric
arrest
and when he arrived he could see
straight away that Finley did not have a
pulse he was unkempt and dirty his
clothes were dirty and stained and there
were obvious marks and wounds around his
mouth and nose
the paramedic then asked both of you for
a history of what had happened that
evening and you both lied to him
you told him you thought Finley had
covered that he was fine when he went to
bed at 7 pm and that he'd been woken for
a final feed around midnight before you
went to bed
none of that was true
Finley was rushed to hospital with you
Shannon Marsden
nothing could be done
many of the marks and bruises on
Finley's body were obvious to the
doctors who saw him and tried to revive
him
you Shannon Marsden told various lies to
the doctors that night when they were
trying to understand what had happened
to Finley in the days before he died
you Stephen Bowden arrived at the
hospital at 4 20 am
and once there you too lied to the
doctors about the final hours and days
of Finley's life
there is a stand-up process which
follows the Unexpected death of a child
and that process was adopted in this
case
Finley's body was examined by a variety
of medical experts Who provided opinions
as to what they had found
these skilled medical examinations
identified the cause of Finley's death
and revealed numerous non-accidental
injuries injuries to his body
Finley had 46 rib fractures
12 other bones were fractured
these included Finley's pelvis both his
legs both his collarbones his left
shoulder blade and his right arm
the agreed medical evidence what was
that these fractures were all inflicted
between the fourth and 22nd of December
and they all cause thinly severe pain
and suffering
considerable force was required to cause
these fractures
the rib fractures were caused by a
forceful compression of thin his chest
the fractures to Fitness ribs and the
pain that caused to him meant that he
could not breathe properly
pneumonia then took hold in his lungs
and it was that untreated infection
which spread through his body and
developed into osteomyelitis
endocarditis and septicemia
it was those infections which killed him
the fractures to the pelvis were caused
by forceful pressing down on the hip
area
the fractures to the collar bones were
caused by forceful squeezing of the
shoulders towards the chest
or direct Blaze to the fracture sites
the spiral fracture to the right femur
was caused by holding Finley's knee and
twisting the leg
the fracture to the right tibia was
caused by forceful gripping and twisting
the leg
the fractures to the shoulder blade arm
and other fractures to thin his legs
were caused by direct blunt force blows
there were 50 bruises 11 abrasions and
nine marks to Finley's body
most of these bruises abrasions and red
marks were to fill his head and face
I'm sure that the circular bruises on
Finley's head and face were imprint
marks
and they show that Finney was held on
the head with excessive force on a
number of occasions
the Opera frenulum in Finley's mouth was
torn and ulcerated
there were inflicted injuries caused
most likely by pushing Finley's feeding
bottle into his mouth with excessive
force or by a stripe or forceful push
against his mouth
there were extensive areas of burns on
his left hand
the first area over his fingers were
caused by contact burning the area on
the side of his hand and Little Finger
were caused by Flame burning
these Burns called fin cause Finley
intense pain
as to the infections the infection of
osteomyelitis in thin his bones caused
him deep throbbing pain he would have
had a fever discomfort and suffering as
a result of the pneumonia and
endocarditis
the medical experts also identified that
Finley's thymus gland was severely
depleted
this was a consequence of the severe or
prolonged stress to Finley's body trying
to fight disease and infection
from all the evidence I'm sure that the
fractures were inflicted on at least two
separate occasions by sustained brutal
assaults
it may well have been more but I cannot
be sure of this
the first occasion was the 12th of
December 2020
the second occasion was between the
afternoon of the 14th of December and
the morning of the 16th of December
I'm also sure given the nature a number
of other injuries and their location on
Finley's body that he was subject to
repeated abuse on multiple occasions
once the injuries have been inflicted
Finley's daily experience was one of
considerable pain distress and suffering
the consequence of all the fractures to
Finley's body was that it was obvious to
both of you by the 16th of December that
Finley was very seriously injured and he
was utterly miserable
Finley was no longer able to sit up and
play with his toys
he was no longer able to feed himself
everyday activities such as changing his
nappy lifting his arms putting Outdoor
Clothing on him or putting him in his
push chair or caused him severe pain
the pain in his fractured pelvis and
thigh bone could only have been
alleviated by morphine and immobilizing
his body
you also knew that Finley was not eating
his food
instead of gaining weight he lost weight
that was because as he had so many
fractures eating caused him pain and he
was not well enough to eat and on top of
that his body was fighting the
infections that he had
by the evening of the 23rd of December
he was plainly dying
there was nothing subtle about this at
all it was totally obvious to both of
you
I now turn to some of the background
you met each other in the summer of
2017.
we're going to come away from that
sentencing briefly as the cameras there
are talking about things that are uh
delicate within that sentencing process
if you are joining us we're watching the
sentencing live of parents Shannon
Marsden and Stephen Bowden they were
convicted of murdering their
10-month-old baby Finley Bowden on
Christmas day of 2020. at the heart of
this case of course the unthinkable
suffering of a baby and the judge
outlining speaking directly to the
parents they're outlining exactly what
she thinks they were aware of of doing
at the time you knew she said that he
was seriously ill and dying she said you
knew when you called 999 that Finley was
dead that is her the judge's opinion she
says that the last days of Finley Bowden
were terrible to describe deeply
distressing he died in the end of
septicemia pneumonia endocard
we are going to return to the court as I
say some parts of what's being said are
not able to be heard by the public let's
take you back though to what we can hear
now
after the 17th of November
there were visits from the health
visitor and the social worker on the
19th 20th and 27th of November
from what they saw
and from the lies you both told them
they thought things were going well
the true position which they were
unaware of
was that you were both using large
amounts of cannabis were in financial
difficulties were arguing and were not
coping very well with the children due
to lack of sleep and being woken at
night
on top of that there was an inflicted
bruise on Finley's forehead
which the health visitor and social
worker both saw
and you lied to both
by the 29th of November there were
bruises on the fleshy part of thinly's
cheek The Junction between his cheek and
ear and on the side of his scalp
these were also inflicted injuries and
I'm sure they were not the same bruises
seen by the health visitor on the 19th
of November
all right we're just coming away because
as I say uh the ability for us to have
cameras within family courts has only
been around since last summer and there
are of course understandably parts that
the public is not allowed to listen to
We went into one of those uh just now
just to remind you if you're joining us
now we're watching the sentencing of
parents Shannon Marsden and Stephen
Bowden convicted of murdering their
10-month-old baby Finley Bowden on
Christmas day of
2020. uh we are going to take you uh to
the court there is now a continuation of
what we are able to hear let's take you
back to that sentencing which is
important to listen to
only you too know what actually happened
within your home at 218 Holland Road
after the 4th of December
your home was a very small terraced
house
you both saw and heard what went on
within your own house
and you knew that your neighbors could
hear through the walls if there was any
loud noise or disturbance
you kept yourselves to yourselves and
you were desperate to ensure nothing
should happen which could possibly be
reported to the authorities by any of
your neighbors as had happened in the
past
I'm also sure that as time went on you
were out of the house with the boys for
several hours each day
so that if there were any unannounced
visits from social care
they would not find you at home and
could not check up on you and your
children
you were both regularly using large
amounts of cannabis in December 2020
every day you Stephen Bowden went to
collect cannabis from your dealer
usually with one of the children
you both smoke cannabis at the rear of
your house which stank of it
you were also smoking cannabis in the
house and in particular in your bedroom
and that is why there was Cannabis in
Finley's blood when he died
on top of that it's well established
that cannabis causes high levels of
anxiety depression and restlessness due
to lack of sleep
and adversely affects any adult's
ability to parent a young child
all right we're just taking you away
from Derby Crown courts there where the
sentencing of parents Shannon
Marsden and Stephen bozen convicted of
killing their 10 month old baby Finley
Bowden on Christmas day of 2020
continues the judge outlining the pain
and suffering that would have been felt
by the 10-month-old baby in the weeks
leading up to his death she her
assessment is that two occasions of
brutal assault occurred in the days and
weeks leading up to his death he would
have been no longer able to sit up or to
play even changing a nappy or feeding
himself would have been impossible for
the baby let's uh let's listen back in
what is then clear from the evidence is
that something very significant happened
in your home in the early hours of
Saturday the 12th of December
12 hours later you Stephen Bowden were
telling your drug dealer that you were
after more cannabis because
and as you saw there in fact it popped
up on your screens for legal reasons we
aren't able to bring you the whole of
this live uh feed uh from the court the
Derby Crown Court there in the
sentencing of the parents of Finley
Bowden who was 10 months old when he was
murdered by those parents uh it's worth
saying that we we are able as we say to
bring you the Life feed apart from those
areas that are legally sensitive uh so
far the judge reiterating this pain and
suffering of the 10 month old describing
the fact that he would have died from
septicemia pneumonia and endocarditis
brought on by the 100 uh and uh 30
injuries that he sustained in in those
days leading up to his death 71 bruises
and cuts 57 bone fractures and two Burns
in those three weeks prior to his death
he had been returned to his parents just
over a month before he died having been
in care pre obvious to
that Finley had that care order a month
before being born but courts the Court
ruled later that the parents posed no
risk to the baby they ordered him to be
returned to them without any drugs
testing being needed despite the fact
that they had been using cannabis I
think we can now take you back to the
court let's listen in
that is because to get hold of the drugs
when you were struggling to find any
money to pay for them you no doubt
wanted your dealer to somehow feel sorry
for you
this was the first occasion there was
any suggestion that Finley was on well
and I'm sure that by the 12th of
December
Finley have been really seriously
injured and that was why he was so ill
I'm sure that it was on this occasion
that some or all of the rib fractures
were inflicted on Inlet on Finley
other bones may also have been fractured
on this occasion but I cannot be sure
which
on the afternoon
sky is Katarina vitotsi she is at Derby
Crown Court and has been listening to
that Katarina an unthinkable catalog of
uh assault and injury inflicted uh upon
a defenseless 10 month old uh just
described to us uh the scene in the
courtroom uh today
it's been an extremely distressing case
for everyone involved in it even the
prosecution described it as something
that was complex and distressing for
everyone involved and that is between
both police officers and the prosecution
and defense teams of course but we've
also heard Victim Impact statements read
out on behalf of Finley's maternal
family so family members of Finley's
mother Shannon Marsden as well as the
family of Stephen Bowden Finley's father
and the impact on those family members
obviously losing this 10 month old baby
absolutely tremendous describing this as
an event that would haunt them forever
saying that this was an unthinkable
crime and how could anyone inflict Helm
on the any hair of baby Finley's head
even in one of the victim impact
statements a relative of Stephen Bowden
describing the pair as monsters they
said that we will never forget Finley
but we will forget you those sentencing
remarks now coming from inside Derby
Crown Court behind me more extensive
than you would ever really expect given
the complexity and the amount of detail
that has to be reviewed ahead of the
sentence being delivered baby Finley
died with more than 130 injuries they
included bone fractures bruising and
burns two separate Burns at which the
prosecution and medical evidence
suggested had been caused by a lighter
those were injuries which led to Baby
Finley then just 10 months old
succumbing to extreme infections
septicemia which then led to his death
the death that the judge in hertz
summing up comments that could have been
saved at the couple of sought medical
help she said they didn't in order to
cover their tracks
and Katrina we are going to go back to
that sentencing thank you for the update
from your side but as we say the
background has been given by the judge
let's listen in again
if Finley was really really ill on the
17th of December
and by the 18th of December you had both
agreed that you would lie and say that
Finley was Ill because he might have
covered and that you had ordered a
covered test
you both knew full well that Finley did
not have covid and you did this because
you knew that if anyone asked to see
Finley this was the perfect excuse why
they could not do so and why they could
not come inside your house
it was an excuse that worked because you
are both persuasive and accomplished
liars and because of the continued fear
which was associated with infection from
covid at that time
by the 19th of December
you both knew that Finley was really
really really ill with a really bad
chesty cough runny eyes and that he had
no energy and wanted to sleep all day
and you could hear his chest all day
rattling and wheezing
yeah let's uh break away from there and
take you back to Katarina vertotsi who's
at Derby Crown Court and Katarina
interesting there the judge saying uh
that on the 17th or 18th of December the
parents decided uh to lie and create
this story about baby Finley having
covid in order to stop anyone coming
into the home just speaking to of course
if we cast our minds Back to December of
2020 that would have been a very
persuasive argument
foreign
yes the couple repeatedly lied to Social
Services that being one excuse that they
had decided to prevent to present to
Social Services in order to stop people
coming into their home that Finley had
covered but throughout this case the
prosecution said that Shannon Marsden
and her partner Stephen Bowden simply
lied to Social Services they told social
services that they were both drug-free
that their home was a clean and safe
environment and when police attended the
house on Christmas Day 2020 when Finley
was dead they found absolutely the
opposite of that they found a house that
was filthy that smelt of urine and
cannabis and a baby who was dead and
clearly presenting with bruises across
his tiny body there are of course
questions for about what happened in the
months that led to Philly being returned
to the care of his parents the decision
was made to take him into care before he
was born and he remained in care for
around eight months before he was
returned under court order full time to
his parents so that decision will now be
reflected upon there is a safeguarding
review that will look at how it was
decided that his parents were safe to
look after their son but today the focus
on his parents on Shannon Marsden and
and Philip Stephen Bowden as to what
happened and what they did to their son
Katarina thank you we are going to
return to Derby Crown Court to listen to
the judge's sentencing
in the meantime on the 21st of December
you Stephen Bowden had lied to the
health visitor and canceled her visit by
saying that Finley had to have a covert
test
on the afternoon of the 23rd of December
the social worker Emily made an
unannounced visit to your house to see
Finley
you Shannon Marsden had told her on the
phone earlier in the day that Finley was
unwell and you'd ordered a covered test
when Emily came to the door you Shannon
Marsden were outside the house picking
up drugs from your dealer and you
Stephen Bowden had no intention of
letting Emily see Finley
you told her Finley was upstairs asleep
unwell
Emily made it clear to you that her
statutory protection visit needed to be
completed as she'd not seen Finley and
you understood she would come back the
next day
Emily then walked down the hill to speak
to you Shannon Marsden on your own
you told her you were fine and you
deliberately did not tell her that there
was anything very seriously wrong with
Finley
you chose to lie to Emily knowing very
well that she was there to check up on
the children and that she could and
would have given you any help and
assistance if you needed it
Emily left your house that day thinking
that Finley had covered symptoms because
she believed the lies both of you have
told her
your neighbor Amy only heard Finley cry
once and that was in the early hours of
Christmas Eve
I'm sure that the injuries to Finley
were inflicted on him in your home and
when that happened Bindi would have
screamed or cried in pain
the neighbors did not hear anything and
you had to make sure they did not hear
anything
otherwise they might have called the
police social care would have been
involved and the boys would have been
removed from you
you were both determined that that would
never happen
no one heard Finley cry or scream in
pain because you inflicted the injuries
I've described on him together
with one of you fracturing his bones and
the other keeping him quiet with your
hand over his mouth
what happened could only have been
achieved by two people acting together
and together you lied to all the people
namely your family your social worker
and the health visitor who could have
helped Finley and ensure he was
immediately removed from your care
by the evening of the 23rd of December
you both knew that Finley if you're
joining us now you are watching the
sentencing of parents Shannon Marsden
and Stephen Bowden convicted of
murdering their 10-month-old baby Finley
Bowden on Christmas Day 2020 let's go
back
this
you knew that sepsis was a
life-threatening condition
and you both knew that if Finley was
that ill then you needed to take him
immediately to hospital or call 999.
that is because that is what the
information you had Googled on your
phone told you to do
and it would have also been absolutely
obvious to you looking at Finley lying
on the floor of the sitting room dying
and you Stephen Bowden in your evidence
accepted that you knew Finley was dying
when you were shown the haunting image
of Finley shortly before shortly after 7
pm on the 23rd of December
that is
foreign
we are just going to leave there the
record the sentencing of Derby Crown
called the sentencing of the parents of
Finley Bowden as we say there are some
parts of this sentencing that we are not
allowed to broadcast so we will go back
in now
it is a deeply upsetting and chilling
image compared to the picture of the
playful child patting the dog only a few
weeks earlier
you both still did nothing to help
Finley rather you continue to leave him
to suffer
the next day Christmas Eve you went out
as a family shopping in Chesterfield for
three and a half hours with Finley in
his pram
you did that to ensure that in that time
social care would not find you at home
getting Finley ready to go out moving
him in and out of his pram would have
caused him excruciating pain
then in the cold December evening you
all went out for another hour to Tesco
and one shop in Old Whittington
the items you bought included formula
milk for Finley
when you got home Bentley was put to bed
in his cot and by the early hours of
Christmas day he was dead
you delayed calling the ambulance but
once you had done so the paramedics were
almost immediately at your home at 2 32
a.m on Christmas Day and shortly after
that the police were there
they noticed straight away the strong
smell of cannabis
the photographs taken by the police on
Christmas day lay bare the filthy
unsanitary and unsafe conditions in
which Finley was living
the bedding on his was covered in
blood and vomit as were his baby grows
and vests
other bedding which have been removed
from his cot was likewise covered in
blood and vomit and you were both well
aware of this
Finley's cot was after all by Christmas
Eve in your bedroom beside your own bed
these truly
a court so describing the horrendous
events leading up to the death of 10
month old Finley Bowden on Christmas day
of 2020 at the hands of his parents
Shannon Marsden and Stephen uh Bowden we
can continue to listen in uh to that
sentencing
to recover from your house empty bottles
of calpol which in total had contained A
month's worth of doses of calpol
much of which you Stephen Bowden had
given to Finley
calpol provided very little of any
relief to all the pain Finley was
suffering given the nature and extent of
his injuries
Stephen Bowden and Shannon Marsden I
must sentence you both for murder
the only sentence I can pass on you is
one of life imprisonment
it is in any event the proper sentence
for your crime
I also have to set the minimum term that
you must serve before the parole board
can consider you for release
that minimum term will reflect your
overall criminality
the minimum term does not represent the
time you will actually spend in custody
it is simply the minimum period that you
must spend in prison
before your case can even be considered
by the parole board
if they do not order your release
you will remain in custody for the rest
of your life
if they do release you you will be
liable to recall to custody for the rest
of your life
I must set the minimum term by reference
to schedule 21 of the sensing code AS
Parliament has enacted
I judge this to be a case which does not
fall within paragraphs two to four of
schedule 21 and therefore has a starting
point of 15 years
having identified the starting point I
have to take into account the
aggravating or mitigating factors to the
extent I've not allowed for them in my
choice of starting point
Stephen Bowden you are 30 years old and
were born on the 21st of November 1992.
you were 20 years or 28 years old when
you murdered Finley
you have 22 convictions for 33 offenses
which include theft drug offenses
criminal damage and failure to comply
with court orders
in 2018 you were re-sentenced to four
months in prison in respect of two
breaches of a community order
your previous convictions do not include
any offenses for violence against a
person
you spoke cannabis since you were nine
years old and apart from when you were
in prison you always use cannabis
you left home when you were 18 or 19 and
then live with your relatives for a Time
Shannon Marsden you are 22 years old and
were born on the 4th of August 2000.
you were 20 years old when you murdered
Finley
you have no previous convictions or
cautions
you were drinking from when you were
nine years old and using cannabis from
when you were 10.
you were unhappy at home were bullied at
school and got into arguments and fights
with other pupils
you would self-harm had issues with your
mental health and were happiest when you
were away from home with your aunts at
worksworth that was where you live with
Stephen Bowden when your relationship
began in the summer of 2017 and until he
got the house in Holland Road in
February 2018
as to the relationship between you
regular arguments were a feature of that
relationship from the outset
Hugh Stephen Bowden have a short temper
and can get uncontrollably and
aggressively angry
arguments are not one-sided and I'm
quite sure that you Shannon Marsden were
quite capable of standing your own
ground in any argument with Stephen
Bowden
you were not isolated by Stephen Bowden
and you were in regular phone contact
with your mother who used fake to at
length almost every day
you knew how to get help if you needed
it
I'm also sure that you Shannon Marsden
were pushed and hit and verbally abused
by Stephen Bowden in your relationship
with him
and that that was happening in December
the extent of the abuse and violence in
your relationship was considerably
exaggerated by you Shannon Marsden in
your evidence at trial and I am sure
that it did not affect your
decision-making in relation to Finley or
your ability to make those decisions
you both wanted a family but you wanted
it on your terms without any regard to
your cannabis use or the safety of your
children
you hated the involvement of social care
or any of the authorities in your family
you were determined that once you were
back together as a family on the 17th of
November that you should not be
separated from the boys again
you had lied to get your family reunited
and once reunited it was not long before
you were unable to cope with and parent
two small boys the situation compounded
by your habitual drug use
you both knew that as soon as anyone
knew that Finley was injured the boys
would be taken away from you and your
family life would be immediately over
having brutally assaulted Finley on at
least two occasions you continued to
abuse him and you lied that he had
covered so that no one would see him and
remove him from your care and in doing
so you subjected your own baby son to
unimaginable cruelty
there are a number of aggravating
factors
first you were Finley's parents in a
position of trust over him with sole
responsibility for caring and protecting
him in his own home
he was a 10 month old baby and was
particularly particularly vulnerable
taken together these are a powerful
aggravating Factor
second
there were at least two sustained and
brutal assaults to Finley
in Which injuries were inflicted on him
in a number of different ways
the first assault was on the 12th of
December
the second one was two to three days
later
Finley was subjected to repeated abuse
on multiple occasions which included
burning his hand and that abuse had
started by the 19th of November
once Finley have been really seriously
injured on the 12th of December everyday
activities such as dressing him changing
his nappy taking him out of his pram
caused him considerable pain and he was
living in filthy conditions
you inflicted significant mental and
physical suffering on Finley for an
extensive period which was at least 13
days in length and throughout that
period he was suffering mentally and
physically
third you failed to seek any medical
assistance or any help from your family
the social worker or the health visitor
at any point when it was obvious to you
that Finley was very seriously injured
and unwell
rather you deliberately lie to all those
who could have helped you by saying that
Finley had covered so that no one would
come into the house or ask to go near
him
and when he died you delayed calling the
ambulance and then lied to the
paramedics and doctors about the last
hours and days of Finley's life
fourth the murder was committed by two
of you acting together
there are elements as we've been saying
of this sentencing that we are not
allowed to bring you for legal reasons
the sentencing of parents of 10 month
old Finley Bowden who died on Christmas
day of 2020 at the hands of his parents
the judge so far has stated the only
proper sentence that she can pass for
Shannon Marsden and Stephen bowden's
crime is life imprisonment she's added
that whatever minimum term she passes is
the minimum amount of time they must
serve before they become eligible for
parole the judge misses Justice Amanda
tipples is continuing with that
sentencing let's have a listen
20.
sixth I'm sure that you are under the
influence of cannabis when you brutally
assaulted Finley
it is accepted by you through your
barristers that collectively these
aggravating factors justify a very
significant uplift from the starting
point of 15 years that I have identified
in mitigation it said that neither of
you had an intention to kill Finley
I cannot be sure that the brutal
assaults on Finley were premeditated or
that when they happened there was an
intention to kill
however in the present context I do not
regard this point as providing any
mitigation
this is because it's completely
undermined by your repeated abuse of
friendly Finley and the Dreadful cruelty
and suffering you deliberately subjected
him to over an extensive period of 13
days and which culminated in his death
you Shannon Marsden also refer to your
age and mitigation I accept that at 20
you were less mature than Stephen Bowden
and that together with your lack of
previous convictions those are
mitigating factors which count in your
favor
I have also read and taken into account
the psychiatric report of Professor
Julia metzi dated the 2nd of September
I am sure that you were quite capable of
making decisions about Finley right up
until the 25th of December which would
have saved his life
I'm quite sure that there is nothing
about your circumstance at that time or
the domestic abuse or violence you were
subject to that prevented you from doing
so
rather you deliberately chose to do
nothing which meant Finley suffered and
died
neither of you have shown any remorse at
all for what you have done
weighing up these factors the minimum
term in your case Stephen Bowden will be
29 years
from that you must have deducted the
number of days you have already spent in
custody which I'm told is 519 Days
please can Stephen Bowden be taken down
weighing up these factors the minimum
term in your case Shannon Marsden will
be 27 years
from that you must have deducted the
number of days you've already spent in
custody which I'm told is 519 Days
please can Shannon Marsden be taken down
foreign
you are watching the sentencing of
Stephen Marsden Stephen Bowden and
Shannon Marsden for the murder of their
10 month old son Finley Bowden which
occurred in 2020 Christmas day of 2020.
as we heard there the judge sentencing
Stephen Bowden to 29 years minimum
sentence and Shannon Marsden 27 years
Katarina vitotsi is at Derby Crown
courts Katarina the reaction
it has been an extremely difficult
sentencing to hear judge Mrs Justice
Amanda tipples going in to extreme
detail about the injuries sustained by
10 month old Finley by the hands of the
people he should be able to trust most
his mother and father Shannon Marsden
and Stephen Bowden we have heard in Port
Victim Impact statements read out on
behalf of the families of both Shannon
Marsden and Stephen Bowden and these are
extremely moving they paint the picture
of families who were continually lied to
by Shannon Marsden and Stephen Bowden a
couple who told Social Services they
were drug-free that their home was safe
that they were ready to look after their
son after he had been taken into Care at
Birth because of both of their drug use
and in those family Victim Impact
statements the family of Shannon Marsden
describes the memories that we have of
Finley are of a happy chuckling baby who
had all of his life ahead of him Finley
will always be remembered and Always Be
Loved when Finley died part of us died
as well and the family of Stephen Bowden
also having a statement read out on
their behalf saying that the couple
could have reached out to us for help
but they chose not to neither of you
showed any remorse comments also
repeated by the judge in her sentencing
the couple have shown No Remorse they
haven't explained exactly what they did
to their child to inflict such horrific
injuries more than 130 in total
including fractures bruises and burns
and they have crucially never explained
why they did it and the families in
their Victim Impact statement said that
that will be something that will always
haunt them
saying we can only describe you both as
monsters for what you've done we will
never forget Finley but we will forget
you both and the couple Stephen Bowden
now sentenced today to a life
imprisonment with a minimum of 29 years
in prison Finley's mother Shannon
Marsden also sentenced to life in prison
with 27 years as the minimum term the
distressing details of this case will be
remembered for a very long time and
there will be many questions to answer
now by the social services team and the
family courts who decided that Shannon
Marsden and Stephen Bowden were a couple
who were ready and capable to provide a
safe home for their son as I said he was
removed from their care at Birth because
of their drug use the court heard that
the couple repeatedly lied to their
families to Social Services saying that
they were drug-free that their home safe
and he was returned to their care
full-time at eight months whether that
was the right decision will be addressed
in a review into that procedure but the
couple here today sentenced to those
life sentences 29 years minimum term for
Stephen Boden 27 years for Shannon Mars
and Finley's mother
Katarina thank you very much Katarina
they're in a derby Crown Court for us
and we will later be speaking uh in fact
very shortly to be speaking uh to a
trustee from the association of child
protection professionals to perhaps pose
some of those questions raised by
Katarina about whether Finley could have
been saved with more intervention but
the news for now from Derby Crown Court
the sentencing of the parents of Finley
Bowden to 29 years minimum sentence for
the father 27 years minimum sentence for
the mother a life sentence
do come back to us after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Sky News coming up today
the parents of 10 month old Finley
Bowden who died on Christmas day during
covid lockdown have been jailed for life
for his murder you both knew that Finley
was very seriously ill and dying as a
result of what you had done to him
yet you deliberately failed to seek any
medical help for him
also ahead the families who believe
their babies were harmed by the drug
primidos have their legal challenge
thrown out
at least two people die after a Russian
missile struck a hospital in central
Ukraine
transgender women are to be banned from
competing in Elite women's cycling in
Britain
an 11 year old boy remains in critical
condition after being hit by a police
vehicle in Lancaster
John Cleese is the latest celebrity to
appear at the high court as the hearing
continues over phone hacking allegations
and in Flight chaos what happened when a
passenger opened the emergency exit
mid-air
[Music]
good afternoon we start with the
breaking news that the parents of baby
Finley Bowden who died on Christmas day
during covid lockdown have been jailed
for Life Shannon Marsden and Stephen
Bowden who were found guilty of
murdering their 10-month-old son have
been locked up with minimum terms of 27
and 29 years respectively the case has
been described as Savage and brutal the
infant was subjected to repeated acts of
severe violence sentencing the pair the
judge said neither of you have shown any
remorse at all for what you've done
the facts in relation to the last days
of Finley's life are terrible to
describe and very distressing
Finley died in the very early hours of
Christmas Day 2020.
he was in his court in your bedroom at
home
he died of septicemia
endocarditis and pneumonia
the infections which killed him had all
set in and taken hold
because of the extensive fractures to
thin his ribs and other bones
which acting together you inflicted on
him
and I'm sure you did so before the 16th
of December which was more than nine
days before he died
you both knew that Finley was very
seriously ill and dying as a result of
what you had done to him
yet you deliberately failed to see any
medical help for him and you
deliberately made sure that he was not
seen by anyone who could have rescued
him and taken him away from your care
medical intervention would have saved in
his life
and if Finley had been given antibiotics
and the necessary care in the minutes
and hours before he died
he would have made a complete recovery
he would have been alive today
I'm sure that you both knew Finley was
dead when you dialed 999 at 2 27 a.m on
Christmas Day
Finley had by that time being dead for
over half an hour
well that was the judge at Derby Crown
Court Sky's Katarina vitotsi has been
following events from Derby Crown Court
also in Katarina a harrowing account of
the final days of a 10-month-old baby
questions of course around whether he
ought to have been returned to his
parents so soon but today any closure
for the families
well today the families heard that
Shannon Marsden Finley's mother and
Stephen Bowden and his father both
received those life sentences with
minimum terms for Billy's father of 29
years and for his mother Shannon Marston
of 27 years but as you said there are
questions now not only about how this
happened and why this happened things
that it was noted by the judge that
Shannon Marsden and Stephen Bowden have
never explained exactly what they did to
their son and why they did it but also
questions with regards to the process by
which their sum was returned to their
care Finley was in care since birth
because it was decided that before he
was born he would be taken into the care
of Social Services because of his
parents drug addiction and however the
court heard how the pair repeatedly lied
to their families to Social Services
convincing them that they were drug free
and that their home was safe and it was
an environment in which they could
properly care for Finley however under
two months after he returned to their
care full-time Finley was dead in fact
we have just had a statement from
Derbyshire County Council which I'll
read to you saying the sentencing of
finlay's parents after their conviction
for his murder is another stage in the
legal process following his tragic death
and our thoughts are with everyone who
knew and loved him we remain fully
engaged with the independent local child
safeguarding practice review a statutory
legal process commissioned by the Derby
and Derbyshire safeguarding children
partnership to look in depth at the role
of all agencies following Finley's death
when that review was concluded later
this year we will be in a position to
communicate more fully about this case
and I think the timeline of what
happened to Finley is something that
undoubtedly deserves further scrutiny
and will raise plenty of questions for
his extended family as I say Finley and
Care since before he was born returning
full time to his parents when he was
just eight months old and under two
months later dying being found dead in
his home Christmas Day 2020.
all right thank you very much Katarina
vitots you there uh e at uh Derby Crown
Court so we're going to stay uh with
that story and get some more reaction
this time from Dr Kieran Murphy who is a
trustee of the association of a child
protection professionals which offers
support and professional development uh
for government and policy makers working
within that space within the child
protection and safeguarding space uh
good afternoon to you thank you for for
being with us today
and a horrendous uh account of what
happened to a 10 month old baby I think
it's really important that that we begin
uh by saying uh I'm so sorry we are
going to just cut in and take you back
to Derby Crown Court this is a moving
story do stay with us Kieran uh we're
going to go back to Derby Crown Court
for a police statement
senior investigating opposite today
we've seen a mother and father jail for
what is quite simply an incomprehensible
crime
over the course of little more than a
month Shannon Marsden and Stephen Bowden
assaulted their son Finley leaving him
with 57 fractured bones across his tiny
body
the heartbreaking reality is that
Finley's last days
would have been spent in immense pain a
fact that would have been abundantly
clear to both parents
they knew that they were responsible for
those injuries and instead of doing the
right thing and taking Finley to get
urgent medical care
they took him shopping in Chesterfield
town center as though nothing were wrong
in actual fact Finley was dying
voters and Marsden from the moment
Finley returned to their care
throughout the trial
after conviction and even a sentence
have never taken responsibility for
their actions
they lied an obstructed professionals
who were attempting to see thinly to
establish that he was being cared for in
the correct manner
they refused
because they knew that once a
professional saw the state of the home
and the condition that Finley was in he
would have been taken from their care
they conspired between them
to ensure that no professional would see
Finley and keep their awful crimes a
secret
but we now know the truth
and they have paid the price with their
Liberty
I hope that findlay's wider family today
will bring a degree of closure and they
they can now focus on the happy memories
they had with Finley who was clearly
much loved and a very happy young boy
before those fateful days in December
2020.
I would like to take the opportunity to
thank them for their support and
strengths during what has been a long
and difficult investigation
and I would now ask that their privacy
is respected following today's sentence
I want to thank all those that worked on
bringing and Bowden and Martin to
Justice in particular the staff who
worked so tirelessly on the
investigation the crown prosecution
service team and prosecution Council who
together built a case that has allowed
Justice for thinly boating
to cover this space
it's absolutely
incomprehensible and Despicable what
their way have done they are truly
reprehensible with no
consequence what actions they could have
done
the injuries
are the most horrific that I've seen
and the fact that they are the
opportunity to seek medical attention
for that child and failed to do so
simply for their own means is beyond
words
thank you
all right there we heard from the
district Crown a prosecutor for the
crown prosecution Service East Midlands
uh summing up what we'd already heard
from the judge at Derby Crown Court and
talking of the parents of Finley Bowden
as criminals truly reprehensible I'd
like to to come back to our guest Dr
Kieran Murphy from the trust trustee of
the association of child protection
professionals
as we were saying and I think they're
the crown prosecution service really
articulating the horror in this case as
we'd heard uh from the judge
if there is to be a sense uh to us
hearing all the atrocious details of
Finley's last few days it is to try and
stop this happening to another child and
I think it's important for us to start
by saying that the workers across all
the agencies involved uh do an
incredibly difficult job and across all
those agencies uh these cases are
absolutely horrendous for them we must
remember of course that the people
responsible for Finley's death at the
end of the day uh were his parents
with that said in the end the decision
made to return Finley to his parents
sooner and faster than had been expected
was made by magistrates with your
experience do you think it's right that
magistrates who are volunteers who are
unpaid ought to be able to make those
kind of life-changing decisions
first thing I'd like to say is how
shocked and appalled I am by the details
of the abuse that uh listening to
um the judge's sentencing there has uh
shocked me and you know is very very
amount of so I want to send my sympathy
out to Finley's loved ones uh uh first
and foremost
in response to that question we live in
a less than ideal system a lesson Ideal
World my preference is always that cases
like this should be for before before
judges before people with expertise
within the room uh but for reasons only
like the one you've just asked me
after the fact retrospectively we
shouldn't be asking questions about the
expertise of the people making these
decisions yeah and in this case
magistrates perhaps in your opinion not
having enough expertise to be able to
make these calls
I don't know the magistrates in question
but I would say that a family court
judge is always best placed to make
decisions about uh permanency and the
long-term care of a child and of course
there are various agencies involved in
this there's the local uh social care
services there's the Child Protection
Agency there are the courts as well the
last professional to see Finley alive
was a social worker she peered through a
window she saw him alone asleep on a
sofa she couldn't get access to the
house at that time as we've heard in the
center during the sentencing now that
was uh almost a month before he died
I wonder why you think there were no
visits in between that time is that a
failure of the social services
I think that there's a huge context that
I'm sure you're uh
audience would like to know Bell and we
haven't got enough time but again living
in a lesson ideal system we have a
chronically underfunded
Children Services System at the moment
like other services we have around the
country that's lost between 50 and 80
percent of its funding since uh 2010. so
answers to questions like that are
always going to be very difficult
without knowing the specifics and the
context of the case
um you know ideally we wouldn't we
wouldn't be seeing a children alone on a
couch and then not following up but I
don't know if they social worker did not
follow up what I am very conscious
conscientious of is the judges remarks
that these were persuasive and effective
liars and I was grateful for your
introduction there about you know the
diligence and hard work that people
working within the child protection
system put in
and that the people who are ultimately
responsible are the parents we naturally
look for someone to blame
um and yes the only the only slightly
positive thing that could come out of
this is that we learn if any mistakes
were made how we can try and avoid them
again in the future but I I I I I
regularly come back to this point when
I'm asked about this type of absolutely
horrendous case incomprehensible case
just having is that having said what you
said there that we learn every time
what would you learn from this
particular case what would your learning
be from this one
I think I think in this case I mean I I
I tweeted out uh when I read about the
case the other day my concern which I've
been talking about for years that those
who are furthest away from the child are
making decisions about that child those
with less expertise about the child are
making decisions about the child I do
think it's regrettable that the social
worker who had the best relationship the
most knowledge of Finley their voice was
not holding sway within the family call
so whilst the local Authority were
asking for a four-month gradual
uh Rehabilitation home which was which
would have been much slower on the basis
that there were still concerns about the
parents ability to care for Finley that
wasn't preferred over the guardian's uh
uh decision in the court Guardians are
fantastic the highly overworked like
Child Protection social workers but that
decision was preferred when the guardian
had only met Finley once via a WhatsApp
call surely a social worker who on a
statutory basis is visiting him every
month to six weeks since he's been born
knows him in the case
more than somebody who's seen him once
via WhatsApp call yeah explain just just
for those people who may not be very
familiar with the system that that
Guardian that you're talking about is uh
the kafcast the independent Children and
Families Court advisory Service uh
Guardian appointed to represent the
child in these cases and who as you said
had only met Finley over WhatsApp
because of course of the pandemic just
on that had there not been a pandemic
had there not been covered restrictions
do you think Finley might have been
saved
I do think that what we know about covid
uh um and the impacts of those lockdowns
we we talked about it extensively Arthur
labindo Hughes last year very sadly
another very very regrettable case is
that children became less visible we
have an effective child protection
system but in unusual cases in unusual
times the proverbial net of protection
doesn't accommodate children in unusual
situations the the system can't
accommodate a worldwide pandemic as
effectively as we would want it to so
children who aren't being seen we need
to see children in order to protect them
and I know that social workers were some
of the few professionals still going
into homes Health visitors as well but
we weren't seeing them as much as we
would like and it was really interesting
the judge's remarks about how the
parents used the covid-19 pandemic to
perpetuate their lives so for example
saying that uh a Finley had covid uh and
what about in cases what about in cases
like this where the parents are
particularly Adept persuasive in the way
in the words of the judge manipulators
and that they're able to cover up their
crimes incredibly effectively
do you have faith that social services
in their current state are able to see
through uh parents like that or carers
like that
I'm very concerned about the chronic
underfunding of child protection system
Bell and I think that if we need if
we're going to prioritize the children
of this country we need more than less
than eight percent of what's been
recommended by a National Review uh
committed by the government to funding
the child protection system we need it
we've lost so much money over the last
12 years social workers have massive
caseloads I should say that after the
death of Victoria Columbia uh Herbert
laming the law Justice at the time
recommended that child Obsession social
workers should have no more than 13
cases I can tell you my latest piece of
research who's going on at the moment
which is consistent with findings over
several years I have social workers with
over 40 cases the spread too thinly and
what those social workers are saying is
if we haven't got time to spend with
children how do we actually know what
they really need and want how can we be
effective at protecting them if we can't
spend time with them and we need smaller
caseloads we need more investment if we
really value the children of this
country like I think we do as a society
we need to invest effectively in the
child protection system Josh McAllister
asked